حرب دمويه وقتال عنيف بالاسلحه والصواريخ
والطائرات المسيره
اختطاف واغتصاب وهجمات مباغته من كل
الاطراف
والسبب هذه الثمره الخضراء الصغيره
الافوكادو الفاكهه التي اشعلت فتيل الحروب
بين عصابه المكسيك
في ولايه ميتشوكان غربا المكسيك تزرع
فاكهه الافوكادو لكن محصولها ليس كاي
محصول عادي فهذه الولايه هي المكان الوحيد
على الارض الذي تنمو فيه هذه الفاكهه على
مدار العام
لذا وضعها محصولها الدائم في صداره اكبر
منتجيها لدرجه انه في عام 2015
صدرت هذه الولايه وحدها ما تزيد قيمته عن
نصف مليار دولار تلك الاموال اغرت عصابه
المكسيك المعروفه بعنفها ودمويتها وعلى
راسها عصابه فرسان الهيكل فكيف لا يكون
لها نصيب في هذه الثروه الهائله
العصابات هي عمل تجاري واذا وجدوا مصدرا
اخر للايرادات فانهم سيهتمون بذلك وهذا ما
حدث مع فاكهه الافوكادو
[موسيقى]
في عام 2006 اطلق الرئيس المكسيكي انذاك
فيليبيكال ديروني حربا على عصابه المخدرات
استمرت 6 سنوات لكن نتائجها جاءت معاكسه
وارتفع معدل الجريمه والقتل على نحو اكبر
حرب لم تؤتي ثمارها
عكس ثمار الافوكادو التي تمت السيطره
عليها من عصابه فرسان الهيكل والتي فرضت
ايتاوه على كل صندوق يباع منها ومع مرور
الوقت ساءت احوال مزارعين فمن كان يرفض
وقتها اعطاء النسبه محدده كان يفعل به
ابشع مما يتصوره عقل
ماريا ايرين فيلا نويفا امراه المكسيكيه
باغتصابها ثم قطفها لان والدها لم يتمكن
من دفع فديه قدرها 600 الف دولار لفرسان
الهيكل كنسبه من محصول الافوكادو ما دفع
سكان الولايه لحمل السلاح بوجه هذه
العصابات للدفاع عن انفسهم خاصه بعد فشل
الحكومه في الدفاع عنهم
والاستغلال الا ان عائدات الافوكادو في
المكسيك كانت في ازدياد اذ تجاوزت قيمتها
قبل سنوات قليله نحو ثلاثه مليارات دولار
ما دفع بعض العصابات الاخرى للدخول في هذه
الحرب للحصول على نصيب من ارباح الذهب
الاخضر وقتها تقاتلت ثلاث عصابات للسيطره
فيما ساءت اوضاع مزارعين اكثر واكثر
لدرجه انه في عام 2019 ونتيجه لهذا الصراع
المسلح لقي نحو 19 شخصا حثهم ونزح 35 الفا
اخرون بعد ان نشرت العصابه قذائف صاروخيه
وسيارات مصفحه وطائره مسيره
كل ذلك العنف حول ولايه ميتشواكان الى
بؤره للصراع بين عصابه المخدرات بدلا من
ان تكون عاصمه الافوكادو في العالم احد
اكبر مصادر الدخل القومي في المكسيك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]